Kontakte und auch überhaupt ständige
kontaktte haben
bereits erfahren haben ist in dieser
Nacht
ein Flugkörper
in ein Gebäude geschossen worden
landzeit innerhalb des Gebiets des
Atomkraftwerks
repeat und ich sollte wiederholen dass
es sich bei diesem Gebäude nicht um
einen Teil des Reaktors handelt oder der
Reaktoren es ist ein
ausbildungsgebäude dass ich nebenan
befindet
dies kostet localized fire und das hat
ein
stattlich begrenztes Feuer ausgelöst
dass durch die
örtlichen Feuer wer Leute gelöscht
werden konnte
wichtig zu sagen dass die ganzen
Sicherheitssysteme der sechs Reaktoren
im Atomkraftwerk allesamt nicht also
überhaupt nicht betroffen waren
und
radioaktives Material ist nicht
ausgetreten
important
wichtig ist sind die
Systeme die die Strahlung messen
die funktionieren vollkommen
unbeeinträchtigt
wie sie sich jedoch vorstellen können
sind die Betreibergesellschaft und die
Regulierungsbehörde extrem natürlich
beunruhigt und sagt die Zeiten sind
natürlich sehr
schwierig wir befinden uns in unter
großen Druck
auf die Einheiten der Reaktoren
von denen gibt es nur eine die nur bei
60% ihrer Kapazität betrieben wird
Einheit
eins wurde gerade gewartet die Einheiten
zwei und drei
sind
in einem Sicherheitsmodus
heruntergefahren
Einheit 1 fährt eben noch mit 60 Prozent
und die Einheiten 5 und 6 wurden bereits
als Reserve gehalten und die Arbeiten
normalerweise im niedrig energiemodus
ich muss Ihnen mitteilen dass zwei
Menschen verletzt wurden
nach den uns zur Verfügung stehenden
Organisationen handelt es sich hierbei
nicht um
das Bedienpersonal und auch nicht um
Sicherheitspersonal
dies sind die Fakten wir bleiben
weiterhin mit den
Personen die das Atomkraftwerk bedienen
in Kontakt
und bleiben natürlich nah an allem was
passiert nun möchte ich gerne noch
ansprechen
und was die nächsten Schritte sind die
wir planen was ist unter diesen
Umständen möglich
wie Sie wissen weil wir uns ja hier
gesehen haben vor ein paar Tagen Plakat
special session of hatten wir eine
Sondersitzung hier und
bei dieser Sondersitzung
habe ich
gesagt
und noch meine Erinnerung gerufen wie
wichtig die Grundprinzipien sind niemals
ein Atomkraftwerk anzugreifen
und andere weitere Konzepte
konzeptionelle Elemente und ich habe die
Mitgliedstaaten daran erinnert
das ist einige sehr klare Punkte gibt
die niemals kompromittiert werden dürfen
wenn wir Sicherheit gewährleisten
möchten
Sicherheit bei jeglichen Atomanlagen in
einem Reaktor oder anderen Anlagen
der erste Punkt war die physische
Integrität
der Anlagen ob es sich um Reaktoren oder
Atommüll handelt naturellager jegliche
Einrichtungen solcher Art das zweite was
ich bei dem Treffen erwähnte war das
alle
Sicherheitssysteme in
weiter betrieben werden müssen
der dritte Punkt bezog sich auf die
Belegschaft die müssen natürlich
weiterhin ihren Aktivitäten nachkommen
können
jederzeit
muss es auch
Notstrom geben damit das Kraftwerk
weiter im Normalbetrieb laufen kann
wir haben uns auch auf die Lieferkette
bezogen die immer ununterbrochen
verfügbar sein muss
falls es beispielsweise ein Bedarf an
Ersatzteilen für Reparaturen geben
sollte
der sechste Punkt den ich mich Bezug war
die strahlenüberwachung und diese
Systeme müssen natürlich auch
funktionieren damit wir eine Idee davon
haben sobald es eine mögliche Präsenz
von Strahlung an irgendeinem Ort gibt
und was auch absolut wichtig ist wie sie
diese Nacht gesehen haben
ist dies eben dieses System weil wir
sonst nicht bestätigen könnten dass ein
Angriff stattfindet
sind uns alle einig genau
kein Land stimmt dem nicht zu dass diese
Prinzipien hochgehalten werden müssen
jedoch ist es so dass dieses erste
Prinzip die physische
Einheit die physische Integrität der
Anlage durch das was passiert ist
kompromittiert wurde
sind natürlich in der glücklichen
Situation
dass keine radioaktive Strahlung
ausgetreten ist
und dass die Reaktoren selbst nicht
beschädigt wurden aber im weiteren Sinne
ist die Anlage natürlich beschädigt aber
wenn wir uns alle einig sind über diese
Grundsätze dann müssen Worte ja etwas
zählen
und wir müssen nach ihnen handeln
für uns ist es also so für uns die
Atomenergiebehörde ist der Zeitpunkt für
ein Handeln gekommen wir müssen etwas
tun und ich habe auch glaube ich
erwähnt das Ukraine dringend um Hilfe
gebeten hat uns direkt angesprochen hat
wenn wir all dies im Kopf behalten alles
was passiert
die Risiken die wir den wir alle
ausgesetzt sein könnten
ohne
uns an diese Grundsätze zu halten habe
ich gesagt dass
in Richtung sowohl der Russischen
Föderation und auch gegenüber der
Ukraine meine Verfügbarkeit und dass ich
natürlich nach Tschernobyl reisen werde
sobald dies möglich ist
diese sieben wirklich wichtigen Säulen
nie wieder in Mitleidenschaft gezogen
werden die Idee hinter dieser Initiative
als Generaldirektor der Internationalen
Atomenergiebehörde ist ein Rahmenwerk zu
schaffen
[Musik]
dazu dienen soll diese Prinzipien
niemals zu kompromittieren über die wir
uns alle einig sind
wir wissen alle dass unter den sehr
komplizierten Beziehung Bedingungen vor
Ort dass meine Präsenz in
diesem Ort natürlich nicht einfach
vonstatten gehen wird
gleichzeitig glaube ich aber auch dass
es nicht unmöglich ist
wenn wir unterstützen wollen müssen wir
vor Ort sein und der erste der vor Ort
sein sollte ist der Leiter der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
ich möchte eine Sache ganz klar sagen
mein
Initiative hat nichts mit den
politischen Aspekten dieser Krise zu tun
das ist ja nicht mein Mandat ich bin
nicht freie Sicherheitsrat der Vereinten
Nationen ich bin nicht der
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
ich bin kein Mediator es hat damit
nichts zu tun da möchte ich ganz ganz
klar
hier drüber sprechen
worüber wir reden möchten ist ein
Rahmenwerk unter der Ägide der
Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde durch
das die Ukraine und die Streitkräfte die
vor Ort sind im Kontext dieser
Militäroperation der Russischen
Föderation sich einigen können auf eine
Verpflichtung
die
Grundprinzipien die ich erwähnt habe
nicht zu verletzen
wie ich also gesagt habe die Sachen
Sache liegt so
der Appell für Unterstützung ist bei uns
eingegangen wir ignorieren ihn nicht ich
bin bereit vor Ort zu sein
das war es von mir und ich nehme gerne
Ihre Fragen entgegen
vielen Dank Jonathan von Nürnberg News
können Sie vielleicht noch mal ausführen
mit wem genau sie auf der russischen
Seite in Kontakt sind sie haben ja
gesagt Atom und auch mit den
ukrainischen Regulierungsbehörde sind
sie im Kontakt wissen wir im Moment ob
der Kontrollraum des AKW im Moment
tatsächlich unter russischer Kontrolle
steht oder
er hat die Ukraine noch Kontrolle über
diesen Kontrollraum
ja wie ich bin bereits erwähnte bin ich
mit Russland und natürlich auch der
Ukraine in Kontakt die Ukraine ist ja
mein natürlicher Gesprächspartner das
sollte ich natürlich immer betonen wir
reden über die Ukraine
und wir wissen jedoch auch und das ist
ja kein Geheimnis das ist eine
Militäreinsatz gibt und dass die
russischen Streitkräfte vor Ort sind
natürlich haben wir etliche
Kontaktpersonen aus der Russischen
Föderation auf diplomatischer Ebene auch
auf technischer Ebene
das ist also der erste Teil Ihrer Frage
der zweite Teil
hinsichtlich des Einsatzes
beziehungsweise der des Betriebs des
Kontrollraums und so weiter da sollte
ich betonen
das bislang nur ukrainische
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter dort
vor Ort sind und die den Betrieb führen
in diesem Fall während wir hier sprechen
haben wir heute morgen um viertel 11
diese Informationen erhalten in
Tschernobyl und in saporte
haben wir eine effektive Kontrolle der
Standorte von militärischer Seite der
Russischen Föderation nicht hoffe dass
der Unterschied ihnen klar ist
guten Tag die PPA German press agency
nur mal zur Klarstellung
sie schlagen ein Rahmenwerk vor
dass die Sicherheit der nuklearen
Installationen beiderseits gewährleisten
soll wie trägt eine Reise in die Ukraine
dazu bei
wir werden
uns austauschen über Elemente auf beiden
Seiten
und wir werden versuchen da ein Konsens
zu finden das ist Teil der Verhandlungen
die wir führen müssen das heißt dort vor
Ort zu verhandeln dass der Plan ja genau
noch weitere Fragen
ich möchte noch mal nachfragen
wer ist denn Ihr Gesprächspartner was
denken Sie das doch normalerweise ein
Außenminister wollen Sie also die
Außenminister von Russland und der
Ukraine als Gesprächspartner ich
spreche natürlich mit den politischen
Behörden der Länder mit den belegten
Vertretungen und das ist etwas das wir
auch wir müssen natürlich wissen dass es
eine Situation ist die noch nie
vorgelegen hat normalerweise ist das in
der diplomatischen Praxis so ein
einfacher Ausweg ist sich auf
Präzedenzfälle zu beziehen so haben wir
das damals gemacht letztes Mal als das
passierte haben wir das und das gemacht
und das etabliert dann eine Art Praxis
oder Tradition unglücklicherweise ist es
hier so dass wir uns in komplett
unbekannten Gewässern befinden und was
diese Initiative kennzeichnet
die der Bedarf tatsächlich zu handeln
und natürlich der Bedarf nach
Unterstützung und wir müssen die
Realität vor Ort mit einbeziehen
vielen Dank
ich habe ein paar Fragen aber ich stelle
jetzt mal nur zwei
wissen Sie wer für den Flugkörper
verantwortlich war der die das AKW
getroffen hat waren dass die
ukrainischen Kräfte oder die russischen
und was haben die Russen ihnen gesagt
hinsichtlich eines Teams das zu
Unterstützung vor Ort sein soll und was
sagen sie zu ihrer Absicht dorthin zu
reisen haben sie ja oder nein gesagt ja
vielen Dank
was wir an jetzt hier verstanden haben
ist dass dieses Projektil
ein Projektil war das von den russischen
Streitkräften stammt wir haben aber
keine Details dazu worum es sich genau
gehandelt hat es könnten unheimlich
viele verschiedene Dinge sein so
verstehen wir bislang die Situation das
ist das was wir jetzt wissen und wenn
sie sagen Ja oder Nein beide Seiten
denken darüber nach
noch weitere Fragen
von Reuters ja ich bin hier drüben
zwei Fragen
[Musik]
was
passiert jetzt genau insbesondere in
saporisha sie sagen die Ukraine haben
noch die Kontrolle über den Kontrollraum
und den Betrieb aber sie sind umzingelt
von russischen Militär was erwarten sie
jetzt was passiert als nächstes
so eingefroren bleiben glauben Sie es
wird so wie Tschernobyl oder denken Sie
etwas anderes
also in welche Richtung geht es und ich
möchte auch noch einmal nachfragen dann
und in Bezug auf das was Albert sagt
warum wenn sie noch nicht
Einverständnis von der anderen Seite für
ein Treffen warum schlagen sie da
speziell eben ein Treffen vor Ort vor
ein Tschernobyl was der Grund dafür es
gibt ein paar technische Gegebenheiten
die nahelegen dass wir es dort machen
damit wir einen besseren Eindruck
gewinnen können
und auch damit wir auch effektiver sind
in diplomatischen Hinsicht deswegen ist
es sehr sehr wichtig dort zu sein
natürlich ist es so dass letztendlich
viele verschiedene Formate möglich wären
was wir jetzt wir zeigen wollen ist dass
die Internationale Atomenergiebehörde
bereit ist etwas zu tun zu handeln und
etwas da gegen zu unternehmen was
passiert und nicht einfach sich
zurücklehnt und von weit her
irgendwelche Kommentare abgibt wir sind
bereit zu handeln
und hinsichtlich sehen Sie mal ein also
ein Dinge hängt mit dem anderen zusammen
was wir hier haben ist eine Situation
die sehr sehr schwierig
beizubehalten ist
und was diese Nacht oder gestern Nacht
passiert ist es natürlich ein Beweis
dafür ich habe schon seit einigen Tagen
gesagt ich mache mir große Sorgen dieses
Etwas das sehr sehr zerbrechlich ist
sehr sehr instabil als Situation
jetzt haben wir gesehen dass wegen
dieses Einschlags eines Projekts
wir wissen nicht genau die Umstände
das wäre nicht möglich außer man hätte
einen forensisches Team vor Ort dass die
Umstände klärt und ansonsten kann man
nicht wissen was genau passiert ist also
sie haben die Situation die wir jetzt
über Nacht bekommen haben das hätte ja
auch sehr dramatisch enden können
wir sollten also nicht warten denke ich
dass etwas in dieser Art passiert
bevor wir
effizientere Wege beschreiten um dies zu
lösen denn wir wissen ja was das Risiko
ist Entschuldigung noch eine Nachfrage
sie haben die Situation ja über Nacht
beschrieben und sie haben gesagt sie
sind in Kontakt mit Menschen im AKW was
passiert denn jetzt also das Projektil
ist eingeschlagen und dann ja jetzt
im Moment haben wir diese normale
Abnormalität
wenn ich das so formulieren darf
ich habe ja letztes Mal bei meiner
Stellungnahme gesagt dass es natürlich
da gibt es nichts normales in dieser
Situation klar
die Kraftwerke laufen
und ich habe sie ja dafür gelobt für
ihre für den Mut für ihre Resilienz weil
sie dies unter sehr sehr schwierigen
Umständen tun und jetzt ist dies
passiert wie lange kann die ist so
weitergehen
ich denke das ist unsere Pflicht als
internationale Organisation mit einem
wichtigen Mandat ist dass wir uns dem
der Sicherheit verpflichten auch wenn
die Zeiten hart sind
reden über Tschernobyl und dieses andere
AKW haben Sie darüber Informationen gibt
es da auch Risiken nein nein im Moment
habe ich da keine Informationen ja
vielen Dank auch dass Sie hier die Folie
aufgelegt haben was Sie hier sehen
sind die sechs Reaktoren 1 2 3 4 5 6 und
in blau sehen Sie
dass dies die Einheit ist die zu 60
Prozent läuft und das ist
das Gebäude
also diese Länge hier ist ungefähr ein
Kilometer
und hier
dies ist das Ausbildungszentrum
[Musik]
das von dem Projektil getroffen wurde
ja vielen Dank auch dem Team dass sie
das hier an die Wand werfen denn das
gibt einem eine gute Vorstellung von den
Maßstäben
okay
vielen Dank
es gibt also noch eine andere es AKW mit
drei Einheiten in der Nähe von Odessa
Feedback da hätte ich gerne mal ihre
Einschätzung
also die Reaktor die Typen von Reaktoren
die dort
im Betrieb sind die über die machen sich
ja schon seit Jahrzehnten die
Regulatoren der EU Gedanken und Sorgen
ist das etwas worüber sie in Tschernobyl
auch speziell reden wollen und nur ganz
kurz es gibt keine
Sicherheitsstandards für
ordentliche
Prozeduren in Kriegszeiten und wenn Sie
uns das jetzt zeigen wäre das jetzt ein
kalter shutdown von allen Reaktoren nein
nein also es gibt Bezugnahme auf
bewaffnete Konflikte und Unfälle und so
weiter vielleicht hat der viz
Generaldirektor das könnte das noch mal
genauer sagen aber es gibt glaube ich
allgemeine Hinweise darauf oder
Bezugnahme darauf die anwendbar wären
aber natürlich sie sagen ja
oder beziehen sich auf eine
vorbestehende Situation die eher
struktureller Natur ist auf der auf die
Sicherheit dieser Arten von Reaktoren
das ist natürlich nicht die Zeit und der
Moment wo man dieses tun sollte also was
wir jetzt hier tun ist wie reagieren auf
eine Situation die aus diesem
von diesem angefert hat
aber sie sagen der Reaktor der hat ja
nicht so geschützt wie diese Reaktoren
und sie haben gesagt wir hatten Glück
und dieser Reaktor dort hat ja eine
komplett andere Struktur ja ja das ist
ganz sicher so
ja
between line ein keinem Fenster der
After der Negation
der den Verhandlungen
haben sie da einen plan
to assist der Personal von der
internationalen Akt
Olaf Scholz ist vor der Presse bei
seinem